what's up guys
bang bang lunch money time well while
she's trying to get rich wrestlers just
trying to get her lunch money right i'm
here with pelina she's got her guns out
ready to go don't forget the lunch money
is now sponsored by blockfi
you can go get a blockfy account and
earn up to 8.6
apy in an interest bearing account you
can buy and sell crypto on the crypto
exchange
or you can deposit crypto and take out a
us dollar loan and get your crypto
collateral
go get a block fi account at
blockfly.com
again blockfy.com pomp what's up
coinbase went down because bitcoin went
up
to 17 000 i don't know that's how it
happened but yes
uh it went down bitcoin has been on an
epic run it's up over 135
year-to-date it's up over 88 since may
of 2020.
most of you watching this already know
all that and yesterday coinbase
went down the running joke in the crypto
community
is that you know it's a bull market when
coinbase goes down
there is also a belief obviously it's
the most popular exchange
so many people are trying to use the
exchange that crashes
it's just unfortunate that it continues
to crash when everyone is trying to
access it i can't believe that's what
you started out are you excited
uh i'm probably more excited about the
next one go ahead the next bull run
no oh the next topic go ahead oh wait
why
go ahead jake clayton who has led the
securities and exchange commission
for the past three and a half years that
included a number of major changes in
financial markets
said monday he will step down at the end
of the year
2020. it's over for him sayonara
wait why jay clayton's a very smart guy
he's very very like
incredibly intelligent uh he's actually
been
incredibly rational from most of the
things i've seen him talk about
except for he has been very heavily
anti-bitcoin and crypto he has
almost worked against it to a degree and
so the belief is that jay clayton
leaving
early he wasn't actually supposed to
leave at the end of this year but he's
stepping down early
uh should serve as a uh a catalyst a
positive inflection point for
bitcoin and crypto regulation we've seen
what happened with brian
brooks who used to be the uh legal
officer i think with the general counsel
at coinbase
he is now the temporary head of the occ
which oversees all the national banks
uh he has been on a tear just clarifying
things and really trying to accelerate
crypto adoption
hopefully we can get somebody maybe
hester pierce would be interesting
well potential successors of the agency
include former manhattan u.s attorney
preet bharara
who was the lead prosecutor in silk road
so i'm not sure you're getting a better
uh
crypto uh that's fine oh no but but
again that's fine
it's just jay clinton was actively going
against crypto and bitcoin
smart guy i'm sure that he has his
reasons for doing it it just wasn't the
best thing for him
is much better but we'll see hester
pierce that's who we need
hester is awesome crypto mom she's great
that's what she calls
there's also crypto dad did you know
that yeah but crypto dad was giancarlo
he ran the cftc and now he left
next airbnb on monday released its
prospectus to debut
on public markets the company allows
users to book short-term rentals and
experiences while traveling
airbnb made 219 million dollars in net
income
on revenues of 1.34 billion last quarter
wow it's so funny because everybody
thought airbnb would be one of those
companies that really struggled during
cobit
but like it it's prospered can you tell
us why you're dancing
ipo time why are you dancing
i have a small investment in the company
i would like to see airbnb do well
that's all
for those of you that don't know when
you make investments when you make
investments in these private companies
you basically make an investment
and then whether it's directly in the
company through a secondary
uh through an spv whatever it is that
was gone
nope uh then you basically have to hold
it illiquid so you don't have the
ability to sell it
at any point until they go public and so
when it's time to go public you know
i just cannot all right
airbnb is a cool company because it's
actually profitable
that's rare it's not rare i mean most
companies are
profitable startup tech they're not sure
venture
backed going public we got to stop
calling multi-billion dollar companies
startups
they're not startups companies no most
venture-backed companies end up being
profitable the narrative the narrative
in the media is they aren't
but hey news flash they're wrong oh
you're wrong
no most of the companies have another
profitable company that went public in
the last
two years that was uh profitable
almost every lemonade no
yes wait
oh wait oh wait
lemonade stock stores over a hundred
percent on first day of trading
whether the company can achieve
profitability is in question
and and is it profitable it has not been
priced no
hold on a second but you're what you're
looking at is what they're specifically
doing is they're
they're intentionally reinvesting the
profits so they don't pay taxes right
well i'm talking it's like what am i
it's like what amazon did um
so the whole reason the whole reason why
companies reinvest their profits
is so that they can continue to grow and
they also don't have to pay taxes it's
why amazon for example
hasn't paid taxes in a loan so why is
airbnb not doing that
well they probably are reinvesting a lot
of it but they are
profitable okay we'll see all right
let's go move on move on i don't want to
sit here and prove you wrong on
national live television
come on let's go i'm dealing with a
child facts
twitter twitter on tuesday launched
fleets
stop it's confederate snapchat and
instagram stories features
the company also announced spaces a
feature that will allow users to join
virtual rooms where they can engage in
real-time audio conversations with
others
the feature is similar to that of
clubhouse a popular startup
what did i say about clubhouse what did
i say
nobody's gonna use twitter's audio
feature
no they're not and fleets is uh
probably gonna be used it's just not
going to
take out the competitors uh i like
jack dorsey a lot i think he's probably
one of the best entrepreneurs of our
lifetime no one gives him credit for
that he's
severely underestimated uh
underrated um they have really struggled
as a company on a lot of features um and
their stock price has
lagged i think compared to what most
people think they should be doing
i personally think twitter is the most
important
social network out of any of them it has
the
highest income earners it has the most
professional connections all that kind
of stuff
in terms of usefulness it's even more
useful for that stuff than linkedin
but we're gonna have to wait and see uh
how these features play out
so we'll see but i don't think that
they're gonna kill snapchat i don't
think they're gonna kill instagram
uh and i don't think that they're gonna
wait why do we think that they're trying
to compete with instagram and snapchat i
just don't understand
it it's not so much compete with them as
much as like if you see functionality
it's like the news feed like everyone
forgets like there was
there was no such thing as a news feed
before right or like an algorithmic
ranked feed and then facebook uh was the
first one to really popularize that and
now everyone else went and copied it now
you're not
twitter didn't use the algorithmic feed
to try to kill
facebook it just said hey that's a great
feature we should add that feature to
our product as well
well look my little cord was up here you
know hanging on my shoulder like a
little angel
go ahead next who are you today next
amazon all right just dance no come on
amazon is making its biggest leap into
the multi-billion dollar healthcare
industry
with the launch of amazon pharmacy a new
digital
drug store the us-based service works
just like a traditional drugstore with
special added perks for prime members
amazon pharmacy except accepts most
major insurance
with the ability to manage orders on its
website prime members can get free
two-day delivery
jeff bezos lost his mind jeff bezos is
about to be selling y'all air next
straight up this dude gonna sell you
everything he's selling
everything on the digital web he's
selling you books he's selling you goods
he's selling you groceries he's now
selling you farm
pharmaceuticals next he's literally just
gonna next time just literally take a
can
put air in there and say i'll sell you
all air and you idiots are all gonna go
buy it and be like amazon air is so good
okay but like a pharmacy i get
why how is that why because instead of
you don't give
jeff bezos all your medical data no
but you walk into the grocery store and
you give them your facial recognition
the amazon ghost stores haven't deleted
in a year okay but you already gave it
to him i
didn't go in that store you ain't
getting me thank you he pretended to be
on the phone
so he wouldn't have to walk in with me
and why and at first i believed him but
whoa i was in there i was like
i feel like this has to do with facial
recognition
why do they need my face they don't need
my face they can have your face nobody
needs your face
sorry it's like when we do the contact
tracing and we walk in someone they're
like somebody needs to spell the paper
i just look at polina like well i ain't
putting my name on that thing
go ahead jeff bezos is going to sell you
guys there
all right next next is ask lunch money
tell the people how to ask lunch money
just put
ask lm in the comments and plano will go
in and grab our favorites and we'll try
to answer as many as we can
all right we've got like five today okay
quickly benjamin
swenson pomp how has your experience
been with retire with choice it sounds
super interesting and i would love to
hear about your specific experience with
it
uh for those that don't know choice is a
product where you can buy bitcoin in
your retirement
account i did a really big endorsement
deal with them
um i'm a big big fan i actually have 100
of my retirement funds with them
um the whole idea is it's a
self-directed ira
so you basically can roll over your
investment funds
uh or your retirement funds into it and
then you can buy all sorts of
alternative assets
uh i personally have uh just bitcoin
and so you can uh either one buy like
the grayscale gbtc
uh through that account or you can
actually um what's really cool about
this is you can buy
bitcoin with tax advantage dollars and
hold uh
your private keys so if you want to hold
your private keys but you want to use
tax
money to do or retirement money to do it
you can use choice
uh i love it obviously that's why i did
the endorsement deals because i think
that everyone should go and have some
bitcoin in their retirement uh
account and choice was by far the best
way i found to do it so not only do they
have all my retirement money
but you can go to retire with choice.com
pomp appreciate that
that softball right there benjamin
all right next jacob barnett what do you
guys think are the most important things
to focus on to be more
wise watch staying true to yourself all
right i have one
i'm a big fan of mental models if you
can kind of
um read through them and implement them
into your life
you will notice when you are thinking in
a faulty manner
and you know it'll help you uh stay true
to yourself
because you realize that a lot of times
you worry about stupid things
go on i personally think that you should
never focus on being
wise what does that mean just be
yourself
like if you're smart you're smart if
you're dumb you're dumb whatever that's
fine
if you're funny you're funny but like
there's a lot of people who you wouldn't
consider quote-unquote wise
who actually are but that's not their
like branding right so like a comedian
is a great example
a lot of comedians are actually
incredibly intelligent or wise or
whatever adjective you want to use
but they don't try to um you know they
don't try to replicate let's say like
naval ravicon's like twitter presence
right where it's like
i'm going to have these like one line
super wise
uh type of of knowledge instead they're
just themselves and so i think that part
of this is
if you want to be yourself then focus on
that and if
you're interested in being more
intelligent smarter whatever
go read go send a podcast talk to
interesting models
yeah it's just like get exposure to as
many ideas as possible
i don't like you saying if you're dumb
you're dumb like that's not true
that's fine but but to be clear i'm not
saying
that being dumb is a bad thing what i
mean by that is like when my brothers
and i hang out
we're dumb like we're idiots but we're
having
fun doing it and so like we are being
true to ourselves because we're having
fun and we're enjoying ourselves if
somebody else saw us all hanging out
and like i walk by my brother and i
punch him in the arm like all those guys
are dumb
but it sounded like you you were saying
something determined this
like if you're dumb you can't be wise if
you're dumb you can't be
no i'm not saying that okay that was
just that was you interpreting my words
incorrectly
what are your long-term goals in life i
think i know yours
um long-term goals
are to make the world
just a little bit better and help some
people along the way
okay what is that like a silicon valley
uh
thing is that i don't know is that a
silicon valley thing my mine has always
been the same
i always say it and people are shocked
what is it
he just wants to be happy facts but what
does happy mean
it's different for everybody what's
happening for you i got a fantastic life
i literally couldn't be more happy i got
that trillionaire energy jeff bezos
trying to sell air and i got that
trillionaire energy maybe i'll bottle
that up and sell it
kevin carlino what do you think about
the boom
in the retro collectibles market sports
pokemon cards video games etc
what do you think oh well i hear um gary
vaynerchuk talking about
sports cards that's true that's good
uh look i think that there's always
going to be collectibles
uh the big question i have is just
they're out of all the things you can
choose from
you know sports cards video games uh
beanie babies
whatever else is out there uh i don't
have
an advantage in understanding what's
going to be valuable and what's not
other people do gary's a great example
uh my friend
my friend dan fleischman is a great
example on the sports card side um so i
think you've got to really
you know be intellectually honest with
yourself and say hey
even if this market is going to take off
or it's going to be a thing in the
future
do i personally have the knowledge in
order to be able to
kind of navigate it right if i don't
should i maybe actually take my money
and give it to somebody who does have
that knowledge right again i don't i
don't know
specific to each market but i do think
that people kind of get caught up in uh
oh look this thing is hot let me go
check it out and they just start putting
their money places
and they kind of learn by trial by fire
and you can lose a lot of money that way
so yes i think that the collectible
industry is going to be big both analog
right so physical cards you know video
games whatever
but also at the same time the digital
collectibles as well i think will be big
it's just you got to make sure you know
what you're doing in order to uh to kind
of protect yourself is this the new
version of beanie babies
yeah like i mean i've told everyone i'm
super big on digital art i think digital
art's going to be massive
uh it's very small right now but that's
that is a version of a collectible right
art is a collectible
um just people don't think about it that
way because it's too high brow
all right the last two questions are
kind of related but i want to shout out
both of them
david jeffries pomp i am 16 and into
business i want to start a business one
day what is your advice to me as a 16
year old
and the next one is from jacques teal mr
pop
you guys i am here too what advice would
give an
old kid slash young adult to actually
understand the importance of saving
and the how when where and what to start
saving for paulina if he says 100 in
bitcoin please do the bang bang in the
background
so here i have young uh younger brothers
um and my advice to them is the same
thing that i would tell
uh both of these people which is one if
you want to start a business the best
thing you can do now
is get as much experience as possible
and what i mean by that is you should do
two things one you should go find the
people who are the most successful
business people you can
get in touch with and you should try
everything you possibly can to provide
value to them so literally
like hands-on do things that they need
done
because what you're gonna do is you're
gonna literally learn through like
osmosis like just being around those
people you're gonna pick up all kinds of
things
how do they run meetings how do they
think about their business how do they
think about marketing
how do they communicate with people like
all that kind of stuff uh the other
thing is
you should start businesses like if you
want to be good at businesses like start
a business
and i literally don't care if you go and
get pigeons in the park and then you try
to sell them to somebody else
racing yeah like you literally should
just start businesses
uh and understand like most of them are
not gonna work or they're going to be
small that's fine
small caveat here like when we were
kids and 16 years old it was much harder
to start like online businesses it
wasn't impossible but it was harder
it was a little bit more friction now if
you're 16 you can literally
sort of paid newsletter or anything just
like test it now
if it takes off that's awesome if it
doesn't you got some experience
yeah and it doesn't have to be on the
internet like you literally and
you know you can literally go and like
buy t-shirts get them printed and like
sell t-shirts at your high school right
like
anything to get experience is really
important when you're young
then when it comes from a personal
finance standpoint this is
really really counter-intuitive but like
you probably shouldn't save that much
money
people hate that advice people hate that
advice but think about it
if you're a kid and you have 200
right that 200 is probably going to be
minuscule to your lifetime earning
potential right and so if you save the
200
great maybe you can go to the movies
maybe you can do whatever you
actually should spend as much time as
possible though taking every dollar you
possibly can and
investing it because if everything goes
wrong right now
you most likely not everybody but most
likely have a bed to sleep in
you have food on the table right your
parents will help you out like you've
got friends
what if you're in a young adult of
course
there's always things right you'll be
able to pay your rent whatever but
again if you simply do the following
rules one
if you spend less than you make two you
get out of debt
as fast as possible three you have
multiple streams of income you diversify
your income streams
four you save whatever you need to save
whether
it's one month three months six months
worth of expenses whatever that number
is for you that makes you comfortable
save that and then as soon as you get
that money saved every dollar after that
you invest
you have to start investing the younger
you are the greater advantage you have
somebody who's 20 versus me at 32 you
literally have 12 years of compounding
ahead of you
that i don't have i will say um
yes but also no um i think
one of the biggest things that holds
people back
and doesn't allow them to move to the
places they want or get the jobs
they want to have and like the salary
isn't that
great at the time but it's a great
learning experience is student debt
i worked all the way through college to
ensure that i would graduate with no
student debt because i knew
if i wanted to live in a place like new
york city i didn't want to worry about
paying off my student debt every month
when i had other bigger expenses i also
saved money in for a year while living
at home in atlanta at my parents house
before moving to new york that helped me
a lot
and still when i was here budgeting was
like the best thing that you could do
i had 104 i could spend a week that
taught me discipline it taught me how to
manage my money it taught me to
spend less than wait what is it spend
most
spend less than i make um and
yeah even though more than half of my
paycheck every month went just to rent
um i i think like you rob yourself of
opportunities
if you have something as big and looming
as student debt
over your head you definitely get rid of
the debt but the whole point is
saving is for losers and investing is
for winners that's
people hate when i say that but it is
the truth the top fifty percent of
americans who end up being the richest
people right they get the most assets
it's because they're investors
the bottom fifty percent they own no
stocks they live paycheck to paycheck
and they don't have the ability to
invest assets
you will not get rich by getting paid a
salary you're not going to get rich
doing that
you have to invest capital and when
you're young
you have the advantage you want to
understand technology trends better than
most
so tesla bitcoin all these things
everyone laughs and like oh the
millennial
portfolio well news flash the millennial
portfolio kicked the ass
of all the old people's portfolio why
because that's where innovation and
technology is and so
you understand these trends they're
intuitive to you so you're able to put
capital in places that have a high
appreciation potential
and then two is you have a safety net
majority of people who
are young have somebody that if
everything goes wrong and you go
absolutely broke you'll find a place to
sleep you will not be out on the street
it's not everybody but a good portion of
people so take the risks when you're
young
because at 200 there's going to be a day
when you're older
where 200 literally like you're just
going to be like that's such a small
amount of money given how much money
i've made in my life right now 200
is a bunch but the whole key is grow
your money
don't sit around with 200 in your bank
account and then just be thinking about
like okay i could buy the new ps4 i can
go to the movies
and oh there's a new shoe coming out i
will say
while i was saving in my first years as
a 23 year old out of college
i did put a small very small portion of
my savings
uh into wealthfront which was an
investing app and i didn't know what
investing was i didn't know how to
invest but i was like the s p 500 is
probably a safe place
index funds things like that and over
the years because i continued
contributing
it's gone up and if you're young make
sure you own some bitcoin all right guys
we'll see you tomorrow
bang bang hope you guys enjoyed this
episode of lunch money as much as we did
and don't forget lunch money is now
sponsored by block five
so go check them out there's a link in
the description that you can click on
i'm an investor
a user and a huge fan
what you're a bigger fan of block five
than you are of me
block five is my second favorite thing
in the world behind polina they've got
three products
they can give you a us dollar loan you
can earn up to 8.6
interest on an interest-bearing account
or you can buy and sell cryptocurrencies
on their crypto exchange i personally
use the interest bearing account
there's not very many places where
you'll find up to 8.6 percent interest
on a deposit in an interest bearing
account go do your own research there's
risk associated but eight point six
percent is pretty compelling
so click on the link in the description
say thanks to the folks at blockfy
subscribe to our channel like the video
annoy pulling in the comments
and we'll see you guys tomorrow and be
kind to your friends